[Musik]
hey liebe
heute gibt es einen dollar 312 von mir
jetzt habt ihr vielleicht ein déjà vu
und denkst du hast doch letztens ersten
donath rezept gemacht aber diesmal zeige
ich euch die backofen variante letzte
mal da waren es klassische also ganz
klassisch frittiert die waren auch mega
lecker aber ich habe euch gefragt was er
sehen möchte und ob ihr die backofen
variante auch noch gerne haben möchte
und er hat gesagt klar
immer her damit weil immer frittieren da
habt ihr keine lust drauf und daher gibt
es jetzt einen rührteig es gibt diesmal
kein hefeteig weil wenn ihr dem macht
und nicht frittiert dann finde ich
schlecht ein bisschen trocken daher
zeige ich euch hier die zutaten für
einen richtig leckeren donath rührteig
und dafür benötigen wir die sind auf
zimmertemperatur das ist ganz wichtig
außerdem weiter also zimmer warme butter
hier habe ich milch die werde ich gleich
eine mikrowelle erhitzen ihr merkt schon
alles hier auf zimmertemperatur außerdem
zucker backpulver und mehl und dann habe
ich hier noch eine zitrone das sollte
eine bio zitrone sein salz und wandel
der extrakt jetzt drücken wir den teig
in der küchenmaschine können natürlich
alternative handrührgerät verwenden und
ihr findet meine zutaten immer in der
video beschreibung unter dem titel und
ihr seht schon ich habe hier die ganzen
zutaten von kaufland dar
ich gehe ja immer gerne zu kaufen das
wissen alle die mir zum beispiel auf
instagram folgen und dann könnt ihr euch
zum beispiel in der video beschreibung
direkt in screenshot machen und dann
direkt damit zum nächsten kaufland und
einkaufen und direkt loslegen
das mache ich jetzt auch ich denke
direkt los gibt die zimmer warme butter
in die rührschüssel und da gibt ihr
unbedingt schon zucker mit dazu und dann
wird das drei minuten lang richtig schön
cremig geschlagen
[Musik]
nach den drei minuten dann einfach ganz
kurz die eier unterrühren in
zitronenschalen abrieb vanille extrakt
und eine ordentliche prise salz und
jetzt geht es weiter mit den trockenen
zutaten das heißt mit dem meer und dem
backpulver und das vermenge ich immer
vorab in einer schüssel dann verbindet
sich das einfach besser und das gehen
wir jetzt nur noch abwechselnd mit der
milch die ich gerade in der mikrowelle
erwärmt habe einfach in die masse dass
ich noch ganz kurz eingerührt und dann
ist der tag auch schon fertig
[Musik]
da der teig ich jetzt wirklich ruckzuck
und jetzt will ich mir einen
spritzbeutel und für den teig 1
ich habe nämlich heute meine donath
formen die ist natürlich ganz wichtig
wenn ihr diese donuts im backofen machen
möchtet und die spricht gleich noch mit
ein bisschen back trends bringen damit
sich das auch besser löst und dann geht
er auch schon gepackt was kann ich ja
schon mal die backzeit verraten und zwar
sind das 180 grad ober und unterhitze
bitte ganz wichtig vorheizen und dann
dauert ungefähr 14 bis maximal 15
minuten und ich war noch kleinen tipp
dazwischen schieben bevor ihn backt
achtet darauf dass ihr die form nur
maximal zur hälfte fühlt wenn nicht
sogar ein drittel weil die noch sehr
aufgehen werden nach dem backen
[Musik]
und nach dem backen nach lust und laune
dekorieren das ist für mich immer das
spaßigste teil das hast du mich richtig
da komme ich so richtig runter kennt ihr
das auf jeden fall nehme ich heute zimt
zucker zimt und zucker ganz einfach
miteinander vermengt und was ich heute
nehme ist wieder meine heißgeliebte
freue mich kuvertüre das liebe ich auch
donuts ihr könnt natürlich auch zart
bitter nehmen oder weiße das ist auch
kein problem
oder er nimmt eine schokolade eurer wahl
mit geschmack einfach schmelzen in der
mikrowelle bei niedriger wattzahl dann
könnte die donuts beeindrucken das ist
total easy aber hauptsache die schöne
seite kommt nach oben die schöne runde
die tunke ich jetzt ein und dann gebe
ich vielleicht noch mandelkow kann oder
ein paar streusel drauf ich kann da
haben sie auch mal entscheiden was er
möchte alles so oft vor den videos ja du
kannst gleich auch schon mit dekorieren
[Musik]
die donut die aus dem backofen kommt
halten jetzt nicht so lange wie
frittierte donald also die halten jetzt
maximal zwei tage auf jeden fall
luftdicht verpacken also es sollte so
wenig wie möglich mit luft in berührung
kommen weil er sonst austrocknung würde
der teig und dann schmeckt es nicht mehr
so gut arbeitet ganz frist und schnecken
die ihre richtig lecker vor allem weil
wir in den teig vanille und
zitronenschale haben und ich finde dass
die beiden komponenten so ein richtig
leckeres aroma haben haben sagt grad
schon drei stück verdrängen oder und die
klausur ist machen sie mal eingetrocknet
java das ist ein gutes zeichen das ist
der schritt richtig richtig lecker euch
jetzt ganz viel freude beim nachbacken
ich hoffe dass euch das video gefallen
hat und gerne wieder eure wünsche zu
neuen rezepten die unten in die
kommentare
ansonsten main kanal kostenlos
abonnieren und ein bäumchen da lassen
und dann wünsche ich euch noch
wunderschönen tag und bis zum nächsten
mal register und jetzt kann ich mir mal
[Musik]